[Music]
money watch this morning we are looking
at the biggest money-saving moves you
can make before the end of the year 23
days left in 2021 but don't worry you
have plenty of time to make financial
decisions that could help you save big
when tax time comes around in april cbs
news jill schlesinger is here with more
uh okay so number one tip right off the
bat what is it if you want to reduce
your tax bill you want to put some money
into your retirement account through
work now i know everyone doesn't have
that so i make that as a caveat but if
you just push up the percentage for the
last couple of pay periods you might
save yourself real money come april and
again this is for pre-tax retirement
accounts the other issue is a lot of
people had strange income patterns over
the last year you probably want to go
over to the irs.gov calculator figure
out if you've withheld enough money
because as much as you want to save
money having an unexpected bill in the
future not pleasant so you may want to
adjust your withholding if you're
self-employed maybe you want to make
some sort of payment as a quarterly
estimate what about charitable donations
before the end of the year well this is
a great uh time because amid covid
congress actually was able to create a
way for more people to get a tax
deduction with their giving so normally
about 90 percent of taxpayers they file
the standard deduction you don't usually
get any credit for giving money away if
you file the standard deduction now if
you are a single filer if you give a
cash contribution to an eligible charity
you get a 300 deduction 600 bucks if you
are a married couple and again this is
just for 2020 and 2021 it goes away so
if you want to feel good about your
giving uncle sam will reward you this
now speaking of that in an effort not to
become scrooge some people
are screwed financially by giving to a
charitable cause that doesn't exist yeah
sort of a scam how do you avoid that the
irs has a bunch of rules out and it's
unfortunate that charitable scams are
always a problem this time of year part
of the issue is that you get a call you
get a a an inbox email and you say oh
give to this charity the charity name
sort of seems familiar but it's not the
charity you actually know so before you
give any money please make sure the
charity is legit irs.gov there's a
search tool you can make sure that it's
legit next of course you know that you
don't want to give anyone your credit
card information until you actually
understand that and of course if you at
all concerned just say send it to me in
the mail and i'll try it that way some
people also scam the irs with fake
charitable givings like oh yeah i put
that 10 grand in the church plate all
cash no receipts sorry can i get the
benefit no don't do that people uh i
want to talk about home home office
deductions right uh so this drives me
nuts people have been working from home
throughout the pandemic and yet they get
no deductions oh poor tony there's a
whole show i made a whole show okay 2017
we had a big tax law right and in that
law there was a rule that said if you're
an employee you do not get to deduct
your home or business expenses that's
through 2025. now good news is if you're
a gig worker you're self-employed go
ahead do this but make sure that your
residence before you start deducting you
know a certain amount of my rent or my
mortgage make sure it's the exclusive
use that part of your house for work and
that you've done it consistently follow
the rules but everyone else i'm sorry
too bad i hear you're sounding the alarm
for people who are 72 that this is a
very important year for them yes okay so
there's something called a required
minimum distribution for people who put
money away into retirement accounts
pre-tax the government is asking and is
actually forcing you to take money out
they always do this it was suspended in
the year 2020. if you don't take out
your required minimum distribution from
your 401k your 403b or your ira the irs
will impose a penalty of up to
50
of what you should have withdrawn
required minimum distributions if you're
over 72 don't forget to take it before
the calendar year into your money now
right that's right it's a good one money
watch
dollar dollar jill
jill thank you so much